ich habe den brief seit er mir gestern
an zugespielt wurde einige male gelesen
und in dieser an bizarren wendungen
nicht armen geschichte ist das jetzt der
neuerliche höhepunkt also christian b
der mit vollem namen zeichnet hat auf
einem auf einem din a4 blatt seine
gedanken niedergelegt er überschreibt
diesen brief mit dem begriff
pressemitteilung also ganz
offensichtlich hatte jemand mitteilungs
bedarf erhält er wirft der ermittelnden
staatsanwaltschaft in braunschweig vor
dass sie schon vor eröffnung eines
hauptverfahrens eine öffentliche
vorverurteilung kampagne gegen ihn
fahren würde und bezeichnet dies als
unglaublichen skandal
sahnehäubchen er fordert die
staatsanwälte wollte also lindemann auf
ihre ämter niederzulegen
weil sie nämlich durch eine willkürliche
verurteilung in der vergangenheit das
ist die vergewaltigung wegen der gerade
ein sitzt aber auch eben dieses
skandalöse zitat vorverurteilung
kampagne eine schande für das deutsche
rechtssystem sein kleiner kleiner haken
am rande
er bezeichnet sich selbst in diesem
brief als unschuldige person und das ist
zumindest mutig bei den gegebenheiten
die uns so so so weit bekannt sind bei
der recherche ist ja schon wirklich sehr
viele jahre an diesem fall maddie und so
traurig es auch ist er kann dich
wahrscheinlich auch nur noch sehr wenig
schockierend was löst jetzt dieser brief
in die raus ich verstehe die motivation
nicht um ehrlich zu sein ich bin also
das erste gefühl dass mich beschleicht
ist verwirrung was will dieser mann
ich glaube dass dieser brief auch den
staatsanwalt ebenso verwirrt und
vermutlich auch seine verteidiger die
davon offenbar nichts wussten
keiner von denen ist zu einer
stellungnahme bereit oder kann dazu was
sagen ganz klar ist dass der verdächtige
sich damit keinen gefallen tut bisher
hieß es er äußert sich nicht also macht
keiner sagt keine angaben zur sache
man muss ihm er ist unschuldig bis das
gegenteil bewiesen ist wenn er aber
dabei bleibt da hatte sich hier
öffentlich geäußert er hat die
staatsanwaltschaft angegriffen
er hat sich selbst als unschuldig
bezeichnet was für seine haft prognose
jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz so
vorteilhaft ist wenn du weiter schafft
ja gerade absitzt und ganz nebenbei hat
er uns in der fußnote auch noch verraten
gefängnisse gerade sitzt das wusste die
öffentlichkeit bis heute früh auch nicht
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren